fairness
okay thank you very much for having me
here
um I want to continue in a similar vein
as one of some of the talks earlier
today and I want to say about how
causality relates to relates to
calibration
all right and that is all you have to
subscribe to the YouTube channel of
course
so this is Joint work with Elias
barenboim and I'm a postdoc at Columbia
Computer Science
um so I want to share the references for
the for the paper that we wrote on
causal fairness and also you can have a
look at our icml 2022 tutorial in case
the stock enters to
um so what I want to begin with I want
to begin with with a basic setting and
in which we're operating in a lot of the
the things that we're talking about
today or sorry this week are are somehow
related to this to this workflow so
basically we have we have the real world
at the current time at time T and what
we're doing is often in data science
machine learning computer science we're
collecting data from this from this
world right and I think I think Franca
had a very nice talk about all the
things that can go wrong in this process
and and so on so after this of course
once we've collected the data the
typical thing we do is we we're going to
plug it this in into some automated
system right and the question that I'm
trying to ask here and I think it's very
related to Cynthia's uh talk earlier is
uh so what happens when we start
deploying predictions from this machine
Learning System is this gonna is this
gonna yield something that we consider
to be unfair or is this going to yield
something that we consider to be fair
right this is sort of a fundamental
question that I'm trying to ask and of
course this is somehow the machine
learning tools that we build they're
going to shape the world in the future
times right this is one of the
assumptions so we need to be careful in
this process right and we need to be
careful about what we're doing okay and
I think the main main punch line that I
have for the for for first first sort of
a key point that I I want people to take
away and I think Cynthia was hinting at
this in the in her talk is that the the
current reality is pretty bad and if you
open up applications and I think some
people have have tried to do this you
will find all kinds of bias that is that
is not looking very good I'm going to
talk about some medical data that we
have we have looked at at Columbia from
the Columbia hospital and from these
large-scale Insurance data sets and I
also want to tell mention a couple of
stories from economics and econometrics
that are that are well known and I'm
going to say why the law itself also
tries to tries to limit some some of
these discriminatory
effects okay so I want to talk in the
context of medicine I want to talk about
diagnostic delays I'm going to say in a
second what that means I want to talk
about allocation of respirators and
intensive care units this is something
that I'm personally very interested in
and in the context of Economics just to
give another example I want to talk
about the gender pay gap which has been
studied thoroughly in the in the
economics literature I also want to talk
about the phenomenon of redlining and I
want to mention that briefly and within
the law I just want to say something
about the disparate treatment and
disparate impact doctrines that are
somehow related uh to this to this whole
story so across a wide range of health
and social sciences we do have we do
have evidence that the current current
reality is quite biased and I want to
start with with the story of diagnostic
delays so basically uh what we look at
what we've looked at we looked at
Crohn's disease and basically it's sort
of for the context it doesn't even
matter what the disease is I'm gonna say
in a minute
how how this translates to other
diseases but basically you can take
patients that are diagnosed with a
specific condition of the of the of the
of the gut and what you what you do then
you align these patients right so all of
the we're looking at the cohort of
people that have received the Cron's
Crohn's disease diagnosis and what you
do then you go go back in time and you
start you try to understand when these
people first started complaining about
their symptoms and what what you
generate through this if you take the
time between the appearance of the first
symptom and the diagnosis this is what a
medicine people call diagnostic delay
right and the question is how large are
these diagnostic delays right and are
they different between different groups
and what we're seeing in and this is two
very large databases what we're seeing
so here I call a total variation I'm
taking the conditional difference I'm
taking the average diagnostic delay for
men and I'm I'm subtracting the average
diagnostic delay for women what you can
see is that there's a difference in for
of around 70 to 80 days that women wait
longer for their diagnosis right so
there's something substantially
different going on for the two groups in
this case and what what you may say and
if you talk to anyone who's working with
this disease they're going to come up
with a bunch of explanations about why
this is Crohn's is specific and this in
that way and the question is is this
really the full story is this just one
disease well the good thing is in in in
in in the world of today there's loads
of data right and what we can look at we
can look at 100 different diseases we
can look at chronic diseases acute
diseases we can look at all kinds of
different things the same pattern is
there and if you look at this plot I'm
not sure how well you can see but this
difference is sort of is sort of
everywhere so you there's even there's
not even single condition where you can
say oh this does not hold
what's blue and what's purple uh so the
purple purple is how long women wait for
for their diagnosis on average and the
other color is is how long men wait so
in some sense there's sort of a
yes sorry I'm color blind so it's hard
to answer that question actually but in
any case the conclusion is the same as
for Crohn's disease across a range of a
range of different examples and that's
that's sort of first example in medicine
okay we have a huge bias right and what
I want to go next I want to go to to
allocation of respiratory there's
another medical context right it's
slightly different not it's probably not
talking about diagnosis here we're
talking about some kind of treatment
decision and uh this this was sort of
very prominent during the covet pandemic
right A lot of people need the
respirators and the question is how do
you allocate respirators if you have
some kind of shortage right and the
question is is there a difference
between between
um men and women when you're doing this
when you're doing this process and what
you can look at you can look at the look
at the the data from the back face rail
Deaconess Medical Center large tertiary
Hospital tertiary tertiary Hospital in
Massachusetts and you can you can
observe there is about 8 percent
disparity so men are far more likely to
get together respirator than women and
the question is of course here you're
going to ask well maybe men have higher
on the severity which recorded actually
is true uh well if you keep if you're
just for everything else so I put in
illness severity I put all everything
that I know about you demographically
and so on you're still getting a large
disparity so even adjusted there's a
huge huge gap
okay yes
yes
everything available we're going to take
of course we don't have genetic
variations here for example but you you
have very good information and of course
in intensive care units are being
monitored very frequently in some sense
and we have a lot of features you know
then you talk about the conjunctions of
this feature and so on I think so I
think so and I'm happy to continue the
discussion offline actually if you're
interested in this example if we are and
we don't have an explanation by the way
talk clinicians in the world have no
idea why this is
uh okay so I want to jump sorry yeah I
don't see anything what paper is this in
I I can share a reference I don't have
uh
yes so uh just in this context what do
you how do you differentiate between
what is green and pink like what what
what is uh okay
I'm not doing that I'm gonna you know in
a second actually yeah okay
um cool uh I want to jump to a
completely different context I was just
now in medical I'm gonna put my
economics hat on and I'm going to talk
about something else so here is here's
some data from the from the U.S
Department of Labor and what you can see
here stratified across different levels
of Education you can see what the
average earnings are for for men and
women in the United States this is from
2022 and what you can see there is that
if you stratify by education and if you
stratify by all other things that are
available right what you will be seeing
is that women earn less for the same job
adjusted for qualifications adjusted for
everything else so this is the current
so this is from the US Department of
Labor right so this is recent data this
is still still out there and for people
who are in in this in in economics this
is not a surprise right I'm not saying
anything new or claiming this is a
finding right people in economics are
very aware of this and what what is
another prominent example and this is
sort of a recent a recent settlement in
which a large a large
large Bank agreed to pay a fine for for
redlining so in short with redlining it
the concept of redlining also well known
in economics the idea is that race can
be sort of correlated uh with with
location of living and Banks if they're
using zip codes to decide on your loans
they cannot it can have a differential
impact on on minority groups and as you
can see here and this is I think this
article is from from 20 to 22 or 2023 so
it's last year or this year this this
happens in reality right so we know that
this stuff stuff happens often so what I
want to say is that I want to I Wanna I
started with this picture of this cloud
of the current world being sort of gray
my claim is this is not great it's very
red and I think this is what Cynthia was
saying today bias is if you open up
medical data economic data bias is
everywhere I think there are some great
examples in text Data I don't think
usually about Text data but I I find the
application is very interesting and what
I want to say is this is 100 bias
according to the evidence that I've
shown and I'm not an expert right you
can talk to the experts in all of these
topics and they would they would
probably have similar evidence and of
course if you're collecting data from
this reality even if you do it properly
and there are many many sort of
considerations in this in this setting
even if you do it properly this data
will collect sort of have an as an
imprint this bias that exists in reality
right and if you feed this into a
machine Learning System and you're
basically
trying to trying to learn what's in the
data you could be just copying over the
existing world and in some sense we what
my claim is we don't want to do this
right we don't want to copy over the
existing world we don't want to learn
the P Star right because P star in
itself maybe maybe very bad and contains
stuff that we really really don't like
as society and instead what we need to
do we need to uh we need to change the
current world and probably hopefully go
in a direction which is which is more
fair and the question is of course how
can we give some guiding principles
about how this this is to be done and
just to mention briefly I don't want to
dwell too much in the interest of time I
just want to mention that the law for
example some of the things that I was
that I was mentioning So within the law
there's there's this well-known concept
of this per treatment which is used
often in employment settings in which
people in which in the phrasing of of
this of this concept is that if you were
to change the protected attribute and
keeping everything else the same you
shouldn't arrive to a different decision
so basically this is causally trying to
measure some kind of some kind of direct
effect and of course the disparate
impact option is trying to talk about
spurious and indirect effects but I I I
I'm happy to discuss this offline if
anyone is interested and of course the
very last concept is sort of business
necessity which is important within the
disparate impact Doctrine and
unfortunately in the interest of time I
will not be able to say a lot about why
businesses necessity is relevant and how
causality relates to considerations of
business SSD but in our paper there are
very very detailed connections uh of
these Concepts
um okay so before I continue as and of
course as a causal analyst you you have
to see some graphs showing up and this
is unavoidable I think or mostly
unavoidable and I I have these three
examples I have this diagnostic delays
example I have the comp example in which
this is from this is from Criminal
Justice I think many people working in
France are probably familiar and I have
the Census Data example in which you can
for example measure the the pay Gap and
what it turns out and this is I think
sort of what we like to call A first
order approximation of what's going on
so there's this there's this model
there's this template model which sort
of fits quite well a lot of the examples
that are that are out there and
basically what it turns out you have
some set of demographic variables you
have a protected attributes that you
single out these two things are somehow
correlated for example location of
living and race or gender with other
attributes and so on and so on and of
course these these two things affect a
set of mediators W so basically x and z
are pointing to W this is what the what
the arrow means in the graph and finally
there's a specific outcome of interest
that I'm trying to understand and all of
these variables are pointing to pointing
to this pointing to this outcome of
course people familiar with causality
and there are some in the audience I
think will know that that the
assumptions are in the app absence of
arrows but I don't wanna I don't want to
go too deep I think this is like you
know find this discussion for those that
are interested but bear with me for a
moment and let me assume a graph like
this okay
okay so what I want to say and I think
this is this is sort of the first uh
sorry the second main takeaway from from
this talk is that if we have a setting
like this so we have this this template
model and we said in W you can think of
as multi-dimensional so it's some kind
of cluster diagram uh and I give you
some data x w z and y the real research
question I think that we want to begin
with is saying can we say anything about
whether the current decision making
process is fair or unfair so basically
what I'm saying is we need to reason
about whether something is fair before
we we even start to build machine
learning predictors and before we start
to use AI tools to to to make to make
decisions in the real world and I think
I think Falcon made an excellent point
that it seems that once we have started
building machine learning tools we have
only then went back and and thought
about this basic problem and it's very
true and for example in medical settings
and since fairness became a prominent
field people are thinking about the true
sort of of decision making systems that
are driven by human decisions okay so
this is the first task and after this of
course and I think this is where
calibration is sort of very related is
you want to talk about the other setting
in which you have a prediction and so
you have a true true label in reality
and then you have a prediction and then
you have data on your labels and on your
predictions and then there's again a
question of whether this is fair or
unfair right and now here is sort of the
inflection point is that what
calibration is saying calibration is
basically requiring that you exhaust all
of the variations from X into the label
y in the predictor that you're
constructing and basically if you know
that for example some part of this
variation you don't like or society
would deem this variation as bad being
calibrated towards this can pose some
kind of risk okay and I think that's
these are stored with two fast tasks
that I like to distinguish sort of bias
detection or reasoning about fairer
unfair without having any kind of a
predictor and in in presence of of a
predictor and sort of I want to be a bit
more specific a bit more concrete
about about what we can say from a
causal Viewpoint so what I want to say
is that I think this is sort of the way
we like to think about the problem and
I'm here focusing on the on the pay Gap
example that I gave what I want to say
is that if you take you take some
quantity so why is in this case salary
and you look at the conditional
difference between males and females in
this data set so if you think about if
you think about this course of structure
right if you think about what's going on
in in the real world so what you can see
is that there's some parts of the of
this difference that is driven by the
direct effect so in some sense your your
protected attribute purely on its own
causing a difference in the decision of
your salary you can also see that this
conditional difference has a
contribution from the from the indirect
effect so basically your salary your
attribute might be affecting something
about your access to education or The
Works activity you're in and so on and
so on which in turn affects your salary
right so this is the indirect effect and
the third type of variation that we talk
about and this is somehow interesting
because it's usually ignored in the
causal inference literature is actually
the spurious types of variations so in
some sense there's a specific
contribution coming from these sort of
backdoor Pathways between the protected
attribute and the outcome y okay so we
have some kind of notion of a difference
in conditional expectation which breaks
down into these three three different
parts and
what is interesting in the data that I
have actually the difference is about
fourteen thousand dollars per year okay
the average Gap and the salary is about
fourteen thousand dollars per year and
the question is what are these numbers
direct indirectness queries for this
specific data set right and of course
you can go and compute them in in our
current world right this is the data
that is that is in the current world
this decision making is is made by right
these decisions why are we arrived to by
humans and what you can see is the
direct effect is about eight thousand
dollars the indirect effect is about
seven thousand dollars and there's a
minus one thousand coming from the
spurious effect okay so this is this is
what the current reality looks like and
now the question is really are these
values that we're seeing are these
values fair right can we reason about
whether this these values are good or
can we can we say more about these
values and in particular what you can
notice now is there's some kind of
societal consensus that needs to happen
right we need to have a discussion you
need to have experts you need to have
people who understand causally or how
this disparity came about they need to
ask them are the values that we have are
they good or bad in some sense and one
one a very typical one which I've
mentioned is prohibited by law is should
there be any direct effect in this in
this data set right should you have any
kind of variation in the salary that is
not purely mediated by something else
right and I think for the direct effect
I don't think this is actually people
are not very hard to agree on this one
right we don't really want this want
this direct effect and
what I want to emphasize here I think
that these types of judgments are hard
to hard to hard to make if you don't if
you don't consider the the causal
mechanisms that have brought about the
disparity in the first place so in some
sense I think causality can be a very
powerful tool to help us understand what
sort of disentangle what what what the
disparities uh up in the in the in the
first place
okay so the second setting in here I
think is I think I want to sort of uh
invite the people who are in the
calibration research Arena to sort of
think about this in in a causal way is
is the setting in which you have the
true outcomes sorry the true observed
label and you have you have some kind of
predictor and first as I noted so this
this part is not underarmed control
right so this is something happening
outside and the reality we're not doing
anything about this right we have no
control over the setting and what
happens then is as we said we have
Quantified what the direct indirectness
previous effects are in this in this
reality that exists what we do have
control over is the y-hat right we are
constructing something and in the salary
example of course predictions don't
translate to decisions but in the salary
setting it's pretty simple right if you
have a prediction of the salary you can
just assign these salaries in reality so
there's a very straightforward uh leap
from predictions to to decisions right
in this specific example right when it's
probabilities it's it's more complicated
but the question is of course if you if
let's say that we we predict these
salaries and then we deploy them in a
company and by the way people are doing
this this this is not I hypothesize
scenario people are doing this the
question is that at time t plus one what
are we expecting to have right what kind
of disparities are we expecting at time
t plus one and I'm I've labeled the one
I've labeled the disparity so there's a
corresponding sort of notion of direct
effect for the for the predicted outcome
right by hat and I I've labeled it PSI
one so the question is what should PSI 1
be right this is a legitimate question
to ask do we want PSI 1 to be about 8
000 as it is in the original data or do
we want to have a reduced disparity
along with the indirect effect right and
the same question actually goes for for
the indirectness for its effects right
so what should these what should these
values be and
what I want to emphasize now is that if
you if you're if you're thinking about
calibration the implication is that
these values PSI one side two and side
three will coincide with the reality
okay so this is this is what it means
right to exhaust all of these variations
from the from the attribute to the label
it means also that you will you will
keep the the the the values the causal
the the causal values the causal effects
will stay the same for the for the Y hat
as they are for the Y now what is what
is a plausible alternative and I think I
don't think is a bad one and many people
I think would agree with this maybe we
want to set the PSI 1 to be equal to
zero right and what this means is we're
not going to be calibrated any longer
towards this towards the PSI one but
maybe in the in the site when PSI 3
maybe you do want to sort of you don't
want to play with these variations I'm
not saying whether this is the right way
to go I'm just saying this is a possible
alternative to this problem but what I
want to say is and this is sort of like
the main punch line I think from from my
talk and I I hope to get people
interested in this direction is it is
possible and this is this is what I want
to say it is possible to be calibrated
only to a part of the whole story right
so you can be calibrated with respect to
the indirect or the spurious effect
where you don't have to be calibrated
with respect to the direct effect for
example and I'm gonna now go into the
formal result and I'm going to share the
reference for for a paper which we delve
into this in much more detail but in
some sense calibration is a very
important part of fairness but it's not
the whole story that's that's somehow
the the main takeaway from from a causal
analysis
okay so this is the main idea that uh
the sort of the second main takeaway try
and we can try to be calibrated towards
the things that we don't consider as
discriminatory right the stuff that we
do consider is bad and discriminatory we
don't want to be calibrated towards them
right because that sort of takes this
bias into the future time step as well
and uh I want to go through a formal
result on causal calibration I'm I'm not
very very good on time yes quick
question yes
does it mean that like can we achieve
size equal to 0 by just adding eight
thousand dollars
you can solve it in that way but I'm not
sure if that's how we want to solve it
right because you're sort of uniformly
doing it across everyone and I I think
in general what I I've been discussing
in some people it's sort of interesting
to try to formulate new learning
problems and new sort of paradigms that
are trying to do stuff like this this is
what we're very interested in doing
uh if that makes sense uh five minutes
cool uh so I just want to mention the
formal results on on on on causal
calibration and uh I want to say what it
roughly says it's sort of in in half an
hour it's sort of difficult to to
disentangle the exact uh sort of
subtleties in this result but what I'm
starting with there's this on the on the
left here I have this quantity which is
trying to measure whether you're
calibrated or not so behind the bar you
have a fixed value of your y hat
predictor and you have you're changing
the protected group from X1 to x0 right
and you're looking at this difference
well what it turns out
it turns out that there's a way of doing
a causal decomposition of this quantity
so in some sense and this quantity which
is just the difference sort of trying to
measure how calibrated or miscalibrated
you are it has causal variations within
and what you can get and this is sort of
the the the workload in our paper is uh
is you can sort of find two terms and
you can see what these terms correspond
to right and I want to give you I'm
going I want to ground those right so
basically this difference decomposes
into two parts and I want to say a bit
about what these two parts are so
basically if you think about a linear
model this is it's very nice to ground
the intuition I think here because
people can sort of parse the results so
what what the two what the two elements
are in this decomposition of this
measure is the first element is looks at
we we sort of look at a fixed fixed
group of people in our data set so we
take people from group X1 corresponding
to a fixed value of the predictor y hat
and we take the analogous group group x0
and Y hat and what we're what we're
really measuring in the first quantity
we're measuring the causal effect of the
affected attribute on these two groups
right so this is a variation that
naturally appears in this in this
calibration measure and what is
interesting here that we're measuring
the causal effect of the predicted
attribute in the true outcome Y and what
this means is that this means this is
not under our control so this is
something that is happening in the real
world and the decision maker or the from
the person designing the ml system has
nothing to do with the first term and
I've just expanded here in this in this
causal graph where where the
coefficients are sort of represent the
linear coefficients of this of the
system basically what you can see the
first term is equal to the causal effect
so in some sense
the second term which is in our control
uh the second term which is in our
control is trying to offset this causal
effect of the protected attribute so in
some sense what you can see is you can
see a causal causal story and a causal
analysis of what calibration is trying
to do so for every causal effect that
exists from from the protected attribute
to the true outcome what you're doing
when you're achieving calibration you're
trying to mimic this effect in your true
outcome this is how you can perceive
calibration causally and of course I
just want to say you can read this in
technical report 92 on our on our web
page if you're interested I think I've
spoken to some people about this okay
good so this is the formal result I'm
happy to take questions offline I know
that it's sort of packed uh in a short
amount of time but basically think what
I'm saying is calibration has a causal
interpretation and causal implications
and this is this is the formal result in
this direction and uh just to conclude I
want to say how we like the broad
framework and I want to sort of point to
some other problems that we are very
excited about so the way we think about
this we spoke a bit about this
underlying reality current reality that
generates the data that we have what
what our view is that we need to do some
kind of causal modeling to understand
the mechanisms that lead to these
different different disparities that we
don't don't like seeing in our data and
we also need to think about like the
Norms that come from for me to think
about societal Norms we need to think
about legal regulations that that are
that are related to this and then on top
of this we need to construct fairness
measures right we need to be able to
verify whether something holds in our
data or not right and of course
empirically we need to we need to
estimate we need to estimate this in the
Android we need to do some kind of
estimation and I think someone else is
talking about estimation in a second
which is sort of quite nice but what I
want to point to and I think this is
sort of a big distinction which which
which you can read more more about in
the paper is that uh there are three
different tasks that we see in causal
inference the first one is just bias
detection so you can even not have a
machine learning predictor you just need
to see whether there's some kind of bias
in your data the second task is about
Fair prediction and I think a lot has
been discussed on this topic in this
whole week and the third one is is very
decision making and what I want to say
is that calibration is very related to
tasks one and two and but it's just the
part of these tasks and there's much
more that needs to be needs to be needs
to be not needs to be done right in in
sort of complementary to calibration in
some sense and uh Fair prediction I
don't have time unfortunately to go
through this but fair prediction is is
trying to trying to formalize some of
the ideas that work here today but we're
thinking about a slightly different
formalism in which we're trying to
enforce some of these constraints for
example absences of Direct effects in
the in the learning process and so on
right so this leads to some kind of new
new new formalizations of problems and
uh of course this is this is my favorite
one this is the one that I've been
working on most recently is how do you
mitigate disparities over time okay so
you have diagnostic delays how can we
how can we improve upon this if if
there's someone sort of the Colombia
University Hospital who wants to do this
how can we mitigate these disparities
over time and there's a lot of there's a
lot of formalism going on and I invite
people there's in section five of our
paper of the big paper that I mentioned
you can read about a lot about what
we've been thinking and we've spent two
years on on these problems now uh okay
and I just want to conclude in three
lines so first first punch line being
calibrated fully calibrated to a label
that is sort of partly unfair may lead
to to perpetuating unfairness uh
calibration clearly plays an important
role this is I I have no doubts about
this and it sort of is is important in
determining the size of the effect along
causal Pathways that are not considered
discriminatory this is what calibration
is very helpful for and as I said to to
conclude that's part of the problem but
not the whole and it would be great to
to sort of open up other research
questions in in in this direction and I
think that's all for me I hope I didn't
cross the time too much
[Applause]
questions
foreign